okay so get ready to have your brain
have a workout by the time we're done
with the scenery that's a guarantee
because
when i watch him in interviews my brain
if there's muscles it's getting bigger
and bigger and bigger listening to him
uh my guest today is nick bostrom who's
a professor univ at university of oxford
director of future of human institute
he wrote a book where two people that
you may have heard of recommended it to
everybody to read
one man his name is bill gates maybe
you've heard of bill gates the other man
is elon musk and the book he wrote
was called it's called super
intelligence
pat's
dangers strategies 2014 he wrote it
became a new york times bestseller
uh uh he's done many different talks on
tedx 200 different publications i don't
know how many interviews you've done but
2 000 plus interviews
and uh
in many ways he is referred to as one of
the most important thinkers of our age
and the conversation today is going to
be what can we do how what is the risk
of having technology ai robots grown as
advancing at the pace that they're
advancing is the strategy to slow them
down or something else
[Music]
nick thank you so much for being a guest
on valuetainment
uh glad to be here uh let's get to it so
nick so tell us right now with
everything that's going on you got guys
that are talking about uh the ai from
the standpoint of we need universal
basic income this is not that
conversation right you got guys that are
talking about you know ai is advancing
way too fast we should slow it down some
are saying
it's nothing to worry about it's been
going like this for a long time we never
had computers back in the days we went
on typewriters we were so worried about
what movies we're going to do what
televisions we're going to do why is
this such a different time and what are
your thoughts about the negative side
effects of technology and ai i don't
think we should slow ai down i think
it's rapidly increasing in capability
and
that it's not impossible that within the
lifetime of a lot of people alive today
we might see
a transition to a machine intelligence
era
an era where the human brain is no
longer at the
place where the action is and why do you
mind super intelligent machines so why i
believe that this is a why do you
believe that awesome yeah well um it's
um
mostly based on observing the
rapid recent pace
of
progress in machine learning deep
learning okay um the
sense that it looks like
this is quite tightly connected to the
hardware that we have available which is
growing and we can expect to continue to
grow
the
the hardware performance that these
systems are implemented on
and it will probably require some new
breakthroughs as well but if we just see
how far we've come even just in the last
eight years or so it seems
rash to rule out that we might have
enough progress within you know the
lifetime of some current folk
um to get this transition i'm not
uh by any means certain that this will
happen but
it seems more likely than not
do you have are you somebody who you
have kids are you a parent or your
father
okay do so you're not concerned about
you know what role technology is going
to play in their lifetime where
they're still going to have a purpose
obviously it's an odds game you don't
know for a fact but in your mind you're
thinking this is the direction we're
going
is it just going to be a different way
of living for us or is there going to be
a threat where eventually we're
controlled by the machinery
well i think on the downside we have
significant risks including existential
risks this would be threats to the very
survival of
earth originating intelligent life or
ways which could permanently destroy the
future by locking ourselves in to some
radical suboptimal state um but there is
also
an upside to this like if things go well
if we avoid these disaster scenarios
then i think
super intelligence would unlock
a much
bigger and better future for humanity
um
and i'm quite excited about that
potential for actually good things to
come out of this also
in addition to
unlocking this upside i think
getting super intelligence right would
help with a lot of other existential
risks
that we will otherwise be confronting in
this century
such as
from
a synthetic
biology for instance that will make it
increasingly easy to
enhance pathogens and
democratize that capability by making
these tools easier to use and more
widely available you got it so you're
you're familiar with samuel butler's
essay darwin among uh the machines right
the 1863 i'm assuming you are right you
know i might have heard of it but i
don't have it so he says he says uh
in 80 in 1863 he wrote this essay saying
darwin among the machines predicted the
domination of humanity by intelligent
machines
that eventually these guys going to
dominate the rest of us and we can't do
anything and we're going to be having to
bowing down to them do you think that is
likely
to happen well i don't think that would
be a bowing down scenario i think in a
lot of these um existential risks as
humanity is simply wiped out
and the resources around earth and in
the solar system and beyond that then we
format it and use for some other goal
instead
you know the talk you gave on ted where
you're like you know uh if we
measure ourselves against the gorilla or
the ape you know it is so much more
powerful even than the strongest man in
the world
yet at the same time our capability is
you know our brain function processing
thinking all that stuff right so the
edge there is strength the edge for us
is
we can think process issues make better
decisions let's just say so what is our
edge over
computers and ai what edge do we have
well we get to build them
and so we get at least one shot to get
it right if we can engineer them in such
a way that they are actually
a kind of extension of our own will
maybe in an idealized form if we can
align them with our intentions and
values then that would be on our side
and it would be a huge boost for for our
goals and uh aspirations
so
if we build them
because we have control to build them
but at the same time
you you know the world is filled with
good people and bad people right so some
people
you know build things with a positive
motive some people build things with
negative motive let's say the noble
people that build them with a positive
motive what if the ones that are going
to build it with a negative motive
because they're driven by power control
force you know and they build this
machine that's stronger thinks better
you know does everything better than us
if there's one area that they can't
build it to be even the most evil person
in the world say the most evil person in
the world wants to build a robot because
he wants to take over and rule the
planet hypothetically we've seen this in
movies novels that's not the first time
we have seen this or read this right
even at that level is there anything we
have an edge over
the best machine robot
any intelligence that's built by man
i mean for now obviously the machines
are very limited i think eventually they
will become way uh more capable
than any human individually and some
point after that more capable than all
humans taken together
i don't think we will have any edge
from any
you know physical or intellectual
capacity post stats
at that point we would be dependent on
these having been designed in such a way
that they actually
um
do what we
are intending for them to do
um they need to be on our side i think
basically in order for humanity to have
a bright future or even if any future at
all
in this kind of scenario
so the good news is that like while i
was writing the book this was
an almost entirely neglected area
a lot of people working on ai but
hardly anybody working on thinking about
what happens if ai succeeds
but since then there is now an active
uh research subfield working on ai
safety and on creating scalable methods
for ai control that could apply no
matter how smart
and capable a learning system becomes
and some really clever people going into
that field so some progress is being
made there i mean we'll see whether
a sufficient solution to these have
become available by whatever time we
need it which is like when some other
researchers figure out how to create
machine super intelligence so there is a
kind of race on right between
the majority trying to make super
intelligent machines as quickly as
possible and then
a minority working to make sure that by
then we will have the relevant control
and safety technologies
yeah but i guess the way i'm looking at
it is from the risk standpoint right
like uh
you know we just experienced a pandemic
and it shut down america shut down the
world it shut down
europe central america america it shut
down everywhere right and
let's say that was an accident and
that's you didn't it was an intentional
thing that happened great what if
somebody wants to do that intentionally
the power to want to shut everybody down
so then the conversation becomes
uh recently one of the main leaders of
our department of defense just resigned
because he said
the amount of uh intelligence and
experience china has on cyber warfare is
years ahead of us where we can't even
compete against those guys so i'm
resigning that's what he said when the
article came out this was last week but
i'm talking about more i'm from iran so
the biggest challenge historically has
been with iran hey we don't want you to
build any nuclear weapons
fine
okay we're not building nuclear weapons
you sure we're not building any nuclear
weapons can we come inspect sure
anywhere you can inspect anywhere except
these nine places well then maybe
they're building in those nine places
right so
what i'm trying to say is say somebody
is not as noble as you are and if they
really have motivations of power
influence control
how far can they go with ai the next 5
10 15 20 30 years
well i don't know about 30 years i mean
right now we know that
um
the leading edge
of ai development is um
mostly in the public domain in fact
the best researchers are falling over
themselves to publish as quickly as
possible their latest findings
uh putting it on pre-print archive
servers even before it can appear in in
journals
now it's it's very possible that at some
point uh this will shift to a more close
development regime
um and at that point it might become
harder to know
who who is where in in in the race
to uh to develop ai
um but but for now we have a pretty good
grasp um
and uh
i think it would be quite hard
at present to
uh
mount a competitive effort
in complete secrecy because
all the best researchers are really keen
to be able to publish because it's the
way that they can show to the other
researchers how good they are right if
you're just doing something in the
bowels of some corporation and you're
not allowed to tell anybody about it uh
it kind of sucks if you're one of these
people who could get worldwide fame or
or you know renown amongst your fellow
researchers um and
at the moment
really great ai researchers is in such
strong demand that they can kind of have
their pick and a lot of them prefer to
work for uh corporations or universities
that that allow open publishing um
[Music]
somebody some of them again that might
change some of these things change
vary based on the country right meaning
in china is not big on recognition
recognizing the individual everything's
about the collective and iran's not big
on recognition either for the individual
because god forbid if somebody gets too
much power you know maybe a second a
resurrection of the shock could come up
so we can't give one person too much
recognition
meaning
in some of these societies some of these
countries
you're not doing it for you you're doing
it for the country so even the fellow
researcher that wants to get the kind of
recognition in china you can't do it
anyways
so if if somebody wanted to do it it
wouldn't be like hey look what i wrote
here look at this paper i just wrote
here's what i'm working on this is my
findings
and some of these places you cannot
fully
know how advanced they are so
maybe let me take this in a different
angle than then but china is publishing
a lot of uh
papers in ai more and more every year uh
that there's like a kind of strong
incentive structure in china to publish
because like academics get rewards
depending on how many papers they
publish and so on and so forth
and from what you're seeing is what what
uh where are you saying the seeing the
biggest advancement so
hypothetically like in your world
what is some technology that they're
talking about being built today
that maybe we saw in a movie 20 years
ago 40 years ago that could become a
reality
well do you mean within ai or within a
year yeah well
um so
so there's like a kind of basic progress
on techniques that can be applied
they're pretty general purpose so if you
look at some of the more impressive
recent advances with large language
models for example
open ai's gpt-3
which has i mean to simplify it's
ingested a huge amount of human written
text basically the internet
and you can then give it some text
prompt and it will
kind of continue writing
in in response to this prompt maybe the
style that the prompt suggests
and
it can write some paragraphs of text
um that
can still in most cases easily be uh
distinguished from human written prose
but in some cases maybe for a paragraph
or so can trick you into thinking that
it was a human writing it and with
occasional glimpses of sort of
surprising
uh incisiveness
now it looks like
the performance of these large language
models
uh scales with the amount of compute so
the more parameters the more data you
have
the better the these models become
and it's a one interesting question is
as we scale up these models by maybe a
few orders of magnitude does that mean
that we will
really close in on the gap between the
current models and
what the ground human can do um it also
turns out that basically the same
architectures that you can be used to do
this kind of text generation you can
apply
uh for other modalities so there are now
system like the clip system where you
combine text
and imagery and you can have
uh either generate imagery or you could
have like input text and you could kind
of imagine what
a picture of that might look like and
kind of
in in a multimodal way fuse these
different information strings that that
we humans have and that that our brains
interpret
in in a quite neat way so that's like
one thing like another recent thing was
alpha fault two by deep mind the uh
ai that is able to uh
if not solve the protein folding problem
at least make like a dramatic amount of
progress there
um
with
potentially important applications in
the biosciences
um
you know if we if we go back a couple of
years obviously that was alphago you
know where
the game of gold was uh
conquered by ais and in all of these
cases it's it's a relatively
small set of techniques that are being
applied and reapplied so it's not like
each of each of these systems requires
some degree of hard crafting but the
real engine the real juice is kind of
this cons this design knowledge we now
have how to make machines learn
we have really figured out how to make
machines learn and that can then be
applied to vision or to sound or to text
uh or to pretty much any domain
um so so that's i think that's like
probably the most exciting thing that is
currently happening is this deep
learning revolution do you think it's
possible to make a to teach machines not
just how to learn but how to feel
i think there's a lot of uncertainty
about
the philosophy of mind question about
what the criteria are for say being
sentient for having conscious
experiences it's
something philosophers uh have wrestled
with for
for a long time
um i do believe that we will eventually
have
machines digital minds
that are conscious
and that then will also have moral
status and that means that the question
is not just what do they do to us or
what do we do to each other with machine
tools but also what do we do to them
um so the ethics of digital minds i
think will gradually arise as a really
important issue
today it's a little bit outside the
overturned window it's a kind of like a
thing that you can't really but but
i think the time has come now where at
least some people have the luxury to be
like you know in academia sitting and
thinking about things
all day long uh when we should start to
try to work out some of what this might
look like a world where say humans and
ai's at different levels of capability
and at different levels of sentience
have to coexist in some kind of workable
harmony
you ever seen a movie her
with joaquin phoenix
do you know which one i'm talking about
where he's
yeah that's one where they have like the
personal assistant right yeah
yeah do you think it's ever going to
come a time where
man
marries a
robot because a robot can now do
everything and anything that another
human being can do
including feel you think that day is
ahead of us
well i mean ever it's a long time right
so
um
but in terms of chat robots and stuff
like that that might be kind of rather
around the corner i mean already exist
in limited ways
it might be that at least for some
applications you don't really even need
a fully convincing
human-like interlocutor it might be that
the more limited thing will still be
compelling to some people
um
and
meaning maybe it will have utility as
well i mean if you have like these
personal assistants like siri or
and if they could start having a more
kind of
social relationship with the user as
well and
you know learn
to say encouraging things when they
detect signs of somebody feeling down or
like i i could imagine that that in in a
small and gradual way starting to happen
within the next few years
um
but um but ultimately yeah i mean if you
have machines that are
completely equivalent to humans
or or beyond that and that are conscious
etc then i don't see any reason why
you couldn't have the same deep
relationships
between some humans and some machines as
you currently have between
some humans
you you've uh you've argued that true ai
if it's realized might pose a danger
that exceeds
every previous threat from technology
even nuclear weapons
and that if its development is not
managed carefully humanity risks
engineering get its own extinction
has your position changed with that are
you still in the same place with that
yeah i mean in terms of the magnitude of
threat if we're talking about
probability that obviously
goes up and down over time so
when
uh
scientists first detonated
an atomic bomb the trinity test um
that was some concern that
maybe the high temperatures that would
be generated could ignite the atmosphere
then that would kill our life
concerned enough that
a number of studies were commissioned by
uh
robert oppenheimer was the director of
the lasalla muslim and
those calculations that were performed
show that this
shouldn't happen
like in terms of the nuclear physics
like the new atmosphere is not ignitable
um and of course they detonated a bomb
and the atmosphere didn't ignite which
is a good thing for us
but at the time you might say that was a
small
existential risk that their calculations
maybe could have been mistaken and then
that would have been the end and in fact
just a few years later when
scientists were
developing the fusion bomb the the
hydrogen bomb
they again made some calculations as to
the yield of this experimental device
that they were going to detonate
and
they set it up
um
castle bravo uh detonation and and there
turned out there was a mistake in their
calculation with the result that the
yield was uh two and a half times bigger
than they had anticipated and so what
this meant was that
a huge blast arose
irradiating a japanese fishing boat
where one person died causing an
international accident you could imagine
the japanese be kind of sensitive to
nuclear after what they had gone through
several islands had to be evacuated and
it was like a big calamity a lot of the
instruments they had set up to
to record the detonation were destroyed
by the blast so
it's a good thing that the calculation
error was in this
second experiment rather than in the
calculation about whether the trinity
test would ignite the atmosphere but
then i think there were maybe larger
existential risks during the height of
the cold war where the arm the world
seemed to be on the brink of nuclear
armageddon on several occasions
um
although it's not clear that that would
have caused human extinction
um
but now i think uh
if we're looking ahead over the coming
decades the biggest existential risks
and i think that would be
unprecedentedly big will arise from some
technological breakthroughs we
can be expected to make a super
intelligence being one and then like
synthetic quality being another and
there might be some further areas as
well that could introduce these new
factors into the world where we have no
track record of living with this for
many years or decades or millennia
and we're kind of rolling the dice a new
with these brand new powers
you know typically when something like
right now the conversation that's being
talked about a lot is regulation with
bitcoin cryptocurrency so
you know
one side is saying it'll never get
regulated another side is saying it's
already regulated another side's saying
it's about to get regulated so
but regulation comes up we don't have
control of this the government's got to
come in and see what's going on because
there's a lot of money launching going
on and these nfts we have to get
regulation because
uh some people are using nfds as a way
to launder money okay fine
do you think you know do you think it'll
ever get to a point again ever is a long
time but do you think any time soon
we'll get to a point where
uh the level of regulation on ai
needs to be a global thing rather than a
national thing
yeah um
that that seems likely i mean if if you
have 200 countries and each make their
own
independent choices about some of these
things
then basically we have to assume that
there won't be any larger scale
externalities from these
different technologies
um but we already have a lot of examples
where there are externalities from what
the country does so with global warming
being one example
where if you want to solve that it's not
enough that one country unilaterally
reduce their own pollutions like it has
to be something most countries do
um and with some other things like
nuclear weapons and biological weapons
we have made big efforts to limit the
proliferation of nuclear weapons and to
ban entirely biological weapons um with
a reasonable degree of success but not
complete success
um
so it might well be i mean to some
extent it depends on how lucky we are
with how new technologies pan out but we
might get technology so destructive that
it's unacceptable if even
one actor uh develops and deploys
something
then then we the only the only hope
would be some kind of global agreement
to prevent that
have you seen the the the
recent movie machines versus the
mitchells
the cartoon now we haven't seen it
so my kids are like hey dad we got to
watch machines versus mitchells
i'm like guys i'm good i don't need to
watch this but when we watch a cartoon
it's a good opportunity for me to take a
nap so i'm like okay great let's watch
it
so we put it on i'm watching this
cartoon all of a sudden i'm like
ask this cartoon i cannot fall asleep
because this is actually very
interesting
and it's a cartoon about machines taking
over
you know mitchell's mitchells is a
family and they can't fight back and
everybody unites and
you know they know how to bring
everything together and
and the human becomes the enemy and even
the movie i robot you've seen a movie i
don't know if you've seen the movie
irobot where the robot becomes the enemy
the human becomes the enemy and they
revolt against it
and you know most many times we watch
his movies a lot of these movies
eventually become a reality it's just a
matter of time when you're sitting there
saying are they making a possibility
what could happen in the future
what concerns you the most with the
future everybody has a different concern
future
well probably
conflict ultimately i mean you can carve
concern cake up in different ways you
can slice it or dice it
um but a lot of the biggest uh
existential risks i think arise from the
fact that
the world is splintered and you have
different
actors different groups of humans
currently working at cross purposes and
in tension and conflict with one another
and if they have more powerful tools to
inflict damage on the other side then
more damage might happen
um
now you might say haven't we already
maxed out on that like with nuclear
weapons during the cold war you could
already have destroyed civilization
while
a nuclear weapons were actually quite
difficult to develop and expensive so
you couldn't just have any random person
having their own nuclear weapon in their
garage right it was like something
states only could develop and even then
you needed a big industrial program
et cetera et cetera
and and b they are
relatively detectable so we basically
know who has nuclear weapons and who
doesn't
um
but that doesn't need to hold for future
technologies we might develop with
biotechnology for example we might get
the tools that enable an individual in
the garage to make something
um
that could decimate the global
population
right and and these things would be very
hard to monitor because you don't need
large facilities with
like power plant next door to pump in
energy and you could just have some you
know test tubes and some
chemicals and some biological specimens
um
and there are other ways as well
that the
properties of nuclear weapons were
somewhat stabilizing so it's quite
it it would it was not sufficiently easy
to wipe out all the adversaries nuclear
weapon to be sure that if you struck
first you would be safe
like during the cold war both the soviet
union in the u.s had a second strike
capability so that kind of stabilized
things a little bit in a crisis because
the alternative right
even if you don't want to destroy the
other side like you think that would be
a great shame but if you are worried
that they could strike first
and wipe you out and that in a crisis
situation that could easily result
to each side thinking we gotta strike
now because even though we don't really
mean harm to the others we can't afford
to take the risk of leaving ourselves
exposed the only way to be safe is to
wipe out their
side first and so if if they hadn't if
the technology had not been such that
you could have a secure second strike
capability then you would have
potentially a much less stable arms race
and other technologies in the future you
know might also be more unstable in that
respect
um
and and there are further possibilities
as well but yeah so i think a big
category
uh of risk come from the the the kind of
the fracturedness of the current world
order
um also some accident risks arise more
deeply from
conflict i mean if you think it during
the cold war one one thing that could
have happened is that
uh that would have been a nuclear war by
accident like some warning system
malfunctioned or something in fact
almost happened on a couple of locations
uh with able archer exercises so forth
but the deeper cause of this it would
have been the conflict because it's the
nuclear the conflict that led these
arsenals to be built up in the first
place and to put on here trigger alert
so even if the kind of immediate cause
might be an accident the thing that
allowed that situation to rise where a
small accident could constance was the
conflict
interesting
do you look at it from the standpoint of
uh how ai is going to impact every
industry in a different way
uh you know do you ever sit there and
say well yeah i kind of see this is this
what could have could happen with sports
here's what could happen to warfare
here's what can happen in music like for
example music is
all about math right so
can we get to a point where
an ai can take
and come up with the uh
you know certain
rhythm or music uh that is perfect math
and create any kind of a voice and put
the lyrics together and sing it where
you know the music entertainment
industry could be
disrupted because you know softwares are
making better music than human beings
are like do you ever go deep to see how
each industry is going to be affected by
ai
mostly we are focusing more on these
like um more general questions and i
think once you have sufficiently
advanced capability the answer to your
question is like all of these errors
will be affected and
overtaken by machine but i mean it's
fun sometimes maybe just to think what
is likely in the near term before we
have this fully general ai i mean with
music i gotta say so far
the
results are not that impressive uh of
what machines i think they get a lot of
the more local structure right like the
small little snippets of music would
sound really convincing and good
but the larger architecture and the sort
of the meaning of the whole piece
is something that so far has not really
been produced by this music generating
as but
what we'll see how
how that goes when we scale up the
systems because
in other arts when we have scaled up
basically the same algorithm but
uh it has gotten more of this kind of
holistic context so
maybe that that
might happen uh in in the relatively
near term
these kind of music generating ads
becoming pretty decent you know every
time i do an interview i got like you
know i'll ask 5 10 15 20 questions but i
got the one question that i'm trying to
get an answer for myself it's not even
for the audience i'm trying to get it so
let's see what we can you know i've
asked it i've asked it already a few
times i'm just trying to
get a little bit clearer about it but
for me
it's
you know uh oh
i'm six four and a half 245 okay my best
vertical leap i ever had was maybe
you know 30 inches let's just say okay
it's my vertical lead okay
so
i know i'm limited to how high i can
jump i know my limits on how high i can
jump okay great so i'm limited
in
my ability to jump
in in basketball the highest vertical
leap they've ever had is 48 inches some
say 51 inches but let's just say that's
the number we are limited to how high we
can jump
animals have a limit to
what they're capable of doing we all
have limits right
and when people say you don't have any
limits it's a great motivational quote
but there's a certain limit that we all
have and the sooner you know your limits
and certain areas that maybe you don't
have a limit you can go out and do great
things with
back to ai
if we know animals are limited human
beings are limited to certain things
they could do what what is what is there
any limitations that ai and machines and
technology can have and if yes what
would that be
yeah i mean there are but they are
very high up as it were i mean basically
at that point
we have to look at the
the fundamental physics involved of
physics of computation
and so there are limits to how fast
signals can
propagate we have you know speed of
light ultimately limits how fast the
signal can go from one point to another
so that means if you have a very large
computer at some point
internally there will be
limits to the serial depth of
computation the speed of the serial
computation you can perform because
it'll just take a long time for one part
of the computer to communicate with
another part
there are also limits like the black
hole in it like if you really made a
really sufficiently large
computer eventually the mass of this
would collapse it into a black hole
right
there are limits to uh
the amount of uh
like energy use uh if you want to erase
information there's like a smallest
amount of
neg entropy that you have to expand to
raise one bit of information so if you
want to do irreversible computation
there's limits to how efficient that can
happen and ultimately there's also a
limit in the universe to the amount of
matter we can lay our hands on starting
from the earth today even if we travel
at the speed of light there's a finite
sphere
that we can access things beyond that
will have receded from us by the time we
get there because the universe is
expanding
um
so there are these various physical
limits
uh assuming our current understanding of
physics is correct
um but but there are many many orders of
magnitudes above
uh like i said not just two or three
minutes in terms of the mass we can
access that
that would be on the order of maybe
10 to the power of
uh 20 stars
or so
and each one of those could hold
you know maybe 10 to the power of 30
times more being surrounded than
you know have lived around the earth
today so so there's there's a lot of
room
uh above our heads before we hit the
ceiling of what physics permit
crazy question for you is this possible
okay you seem like you're going to say
yes because
uh your your general answer is anything
is possible with ai because
ever is a long time so eventually they
can figure it out so let me kind of give
this to you and try to
either trash it or say no that could
possibly happen one day
so
you know half the time you
in america especially i've lived in iran
i've lived in germany i've lived here
in america when you vote for a president
people will typically hate the president
because of personal reasons they'll say
i don't like that he's this he's that so
it's easier to demonize
a president it's easy to demonize
a biden a trump an obama a bush a
clinton a reagan it's easy to demonize
because it's a human being right
versus
um
you know if there was no face on the
president it was ran based on predictive
analytics data on what's the best
decision to make with this specific area
because we can run stats and we can
write data to say
the right tax system to run based on the
you know what the system figured out
here with this computer with this ai
we should never tax people more than 22
and a half percent i'm just throwing a
number out there to you right
and
so then
you know this other
situation says based on the amount of
wars that we've gone and the conflict
that we've had with india with china
with iran with this this is that the
right move right now is to do nothing or
let's leave or let's stay let's say five
more months
because it's all data data data data
data data right do you think there could
come a time where we no longer have
people running for presidents we have uh
systems and computers and ai that we
vote for
i mean i think that would come late i
think there's a lot of kind of inertia
embedded in the constitutional framework
so i'd imagine that would probably for
some time be at least a figurehead now
you can always ask how much is this
figurehead actually the thing that
controls what the government does sure i
think you could ask that question
already in the present world
um and i think true
in most cases in history there is like
one sailing figure but then there is
some kind of elite around that there are
some institutions that constrain
their freedom of action and maybe some
of what constrains them in the future
will increasingly be these big
information systems and algorithms
running on them just like today like say
the market kind of constrains
what what you can do as a president and
then maybe
you know there will be social networks
that constrain you and then maybe there
will be other interactions between cyber
systems that also
you constrain what you can do
because what how can you talk to a
system right you're like we got three
systems here to vote for the predictive
analytics ran by such and such
university believes these are the
decisions for us to make and in the last
200 years
if we would have ran it based on this
system it would have done so we can't
get say that computer i don't like he
hurt my feelings or it hurt my feelings
we can't do that but
what you did say with your answer is
maybe
ai does have a certain limit and the
limitation it has is it can never be a
president
i'm trying to figure out well i mean
that's like if we decide that i mean but
i do think that
uh the limit of not being able to become
the object of our hatred i don't think
it's a real limit that wouldn't
underestimate the human ability to hate
and i think we can hate individuals and
we can hate nations and institutions and
companies and systems and all kinds of
things i don't see why people couldn't
bring themselves together to hate some
uh like predictive algorithm as well if
that's what it comes to i guess the part
where i'm going when i have the debate
over god
and i'm the skeptical guy i'm the guy
that got kicked out of bible study in
iran because i'm like if there's really
a god why the hell am i going to
why am i seeing so many people dying why
we're being bombed by saddam hussein so
but the the conversations about god
where logic emotion
feelings you know decision making
process choices
you know to me it eventually gets to a
point where
you know
i don't know if technology can build
feelings
feelings because
you said i'm sure we can figure out a
way to hate something that's a machine
believe me i hated my escalade last
because i had no clue what the hell was
going on with the suspension
so yes you're right i can't hate a
machine because i hated my eyes last
week
okay
and it couldn't figure out how to go
down i'm going down to miami and i'm
bumping all over the place we figured
that there was two things i had to fix
and it was addressed so yes you're right
we can't do that but i'm just trying to
see
what is the one area that we have an
edge over machines
where long term machines are going to
need us rather than us desperately
needing
machines to survive
yeah i don't think there will be such a
area i think if machines need us it's
because somehow they care about us and
either that or there are some other
machines that care about this so that
might give the first machine an
instrumental reason to care about doses
um yeah but uh otherwise i think from a
practical point of view i think
ultimately there would be no physical
outcome that we would be able to produce
through our muscles our brains that some
intelligent system couldn't produce
equally well or better you think so
even i mean
sorry i mean right i mean yeah so that's
like the super intelligence obviously if
they are generally much more capable of
solving problems than we are then true
and and then like i mean is it our
fingers that are going to be
so intricate that you couldn't have a
robotic manipulator that is able to do
the same no i think that obviously with
nanotech they will have much
more capable actuators as well and so
then at the fundamental level there is
nothing we can do but it might well be
that we have a position in the scheme of
values
that makes us uh
very important
i mean this is the same way as like
maybe i have like a a grandmother or
something who is terribly beloved and
maybe she can't really do much she can't
hold the job and earn income or
you know serve any practical but if
people care about her then
there is something only she can do which
is to
be alive and be happy that nobody else
can do that for her and similarly our
role in the future might be the people
who kind of actually enjoy this whole
situation and
the people for whose sake all of this
work is being done and that would kind
of in some sense be a more dignified
role than being the worker and the arms
and the legs
of the whole apparatus so then if that's
the case like intuition you know there's
a different thing about intuition you
sit down with somebody
afterwards you say babe what did you
think about the guy i don't trust them
yeah me neither
you know can can ai get to that level to
have the intuition that we have because
sometimes it's not like you know 19 keys
to have an intuition it's kind of a gut
raising upbringing who you're around to
get a gut feeling
can they duplicate feelings
can they duplicate eyes looking at each
other that contact i don't know all i'm
looking for is this is your world i'm
just trying to get smarter by talking to
a guy
who is living in the world where this is
what you consume 24 7. i don't consume
this 24 7. i'm just trying to get one
percent smarter about the industry
you're in than i was 45 minutes ago and
that's been my goal the entire time so
i'm going to give you the last thoughts
here and here's how i'll phrase the
question and you can answer it any way
you want as a parent
as a human being
uh are you optimistic about the future
are you curious are you kind of like man
i wonder how crazy these things can get
are you like man what is the limitation
on how much we can take technology and
how uh how much can this technology
advance what's your feeling about the
future if you were to say this is my
feelings about the future
i would characterize myself as a fretful
optimist
frightful optimist threatful fretful
got it you want to unpack that a little
bit
it's pretty self-explanatory i mean i
think the uh uh
there is
given our current state of ignorance we
can
preclude either extremely good outcomes
or or very bad ones
and we are living this
uncertainty um
and we'll see how it uh pans out
i like that fretful
optimist
uh nick thank you for being a guest on
valuetainment we're going to put the
link below to your book super
intelligence pants dangers strategies
new york time bestseller we'll put the
link below thank you so much for making
the time of being a guest on
valuetainment great i'm glad we could
make it happen you got it
bye-bye what do you think do you think
ai is going to take over do you think
it's going to get to a point where we
may have a president that's a robot one
day curious to know your thoughts
comment below if you enjoyed this
interview give it a thumbs up and
subscribe to the channel and you may
also enjoy another interview i do with
pablo holman who's a futurist i believe
in a hacker very interesting mind if
you've not seen that click over here to
watch it take care everybody bye
[Music]